the jurgen experience oh
god can you like minority report of like
legitimate serial killers you know what
the problem with that would be
if you could go like if you were
with a baby and you get he said
because of this baby's life and where
he's at
this baby will one day be a serial
killer
i'm just trying to figure out how we got
to just being with the baby with the
scenario i'm just hanging it's not even
your baby but
oh you're at a hospital maybe there's
some like some future prognostication
tools
where they can like zoom in on a baby's
brain and see
exactly where it's going to go i mean
there's got to be something to
having some sort of consistency with the
neurology of
serial killers i think it alters with uh
life
i think it's many things and obviously
i'm a [ __ ] so i don't really know
you say you're a [ __ ] as i'm sitting
watching this beautiful sign lit up
behind you in this gorgeous building you
are not a [ __ ]
i'm definitely a [ __ ] you're a total
[ __ ] but you're a very smart one
compared to smart people you need to
trust me i'm i'm a legit [ __ ]
but i have uh a a way of looking at
things that's
it's i'm a little freer in my
associations because i don't worry about
being fired
right and so i haven't worried about
being fired for a long time so i have a
certain freedom
in the way i look at things but that's
not intelligence
but my point is that i remember my point
what we're talking about we were talking
about more we were talking about no
serial killers yeah um if you could take
that child
and raise it differently would it turn
out to be an amazing person
see like what happens to a person you
know the the concept of determinism
do you know that over free will right
free will meaning that you have control
of your destiny determinism is like
hold on a second it's way more
complicated than that you're who you
are right now is a combination of many
factors that are outside of your control
particularly when you're a child abuse
violence and
trauma those shape a child in very
horrific ways
and neglect one of the things i was
watching a documentary about the
unabomber and the unabomber's brother
ted kaczynski's brother
was talking about how when ted had a
condition when he was a child they
brought him to this place to treat him
and they let this he was a baby and they
left him alone for like
months so during a critical period of
his life
like he had no love no touch of his
mother like this is like
really important stuff i forget how long
the period was
i want to say it was like two months but
even if it was like two weeks like what
does that do to a child
it's got to be detrimental see if you
can find it jamie it was uh
in the documentary that is recently
on i think it was on netflix the he
talked about it
you know so he lived in this shack in
montana and he would point guns in
people and not kill him and then he
starts
riding this manifesto and then he starts
sending bombs to people
but there's so many factors there here's
here's one besides the fact that his
his parents left him in this place they
definitely left him in this place for a
period of time that i think was pretty
extended
i think it was at least two weeks it
might have been two months jesus
he was also part of the harvard lsd
experiment oh [ __ ]
so in harvard during the 19
i guess it was 50s not sure when he was
going to school at harvard
they were doing these lsd studies and um
was it like mk ultra house you don't
know right i would say yeah no i don't
know
they must have had branches for sure
they had studies and they were helping
them fuel their own studies don't find a
time but
this is what it says about it okay um
when ted kaczynski was a at a tender age
he got sick was taken to a hospital
with hives or swollen red bumps that
appeared on his skin
his family said he was isolated from his
parents as doctor tried to determine
what was wrong with the infant
mom always faulted the hospital they
would have been there every day visiting
but the hospital said no
david kudzinski said in the docu-series
it was kind of like we don't want
parents to be in the way
we've got our work to do we have our
little baby to cure so keep your
distance
they were only allowed to visit him two
times a week for two hours
oh my god it's insane i mean so then you
think about
quarantine are we going to create serial
killers a little bit but look at the
bottom
he'd come out and he'd never been the
same after that she said
so it changed him as a toddler
so you got that okay so you've this uh
this horrific neglect that he
experienced as a child through no fault
of his own so free will
we have to look at free will like what
does that mean are you saying he has
free will like this guy with a broken
brain because he was ignored as a child
or people that were sexually abused as
children for years and years and years
by a close family
relative or or family member and no one
believes them
that that's real too right how much does
that change you then he goes on to be a
part of these [ __ ] harvard lsd
studies and then you also have to factor
in
you have to factor in gender i'm pretty
sure that's true but you know i'm wrong
a lot
don't you think you have to factor
gender in a little bit
him being a man yeah i'm sure anger
society he was apparently like super his
brother talked about how he's super
angry when a girl would reject him he
would get furious
and i'm sure with testosterone that is
affected differently than somebody who's
you know
female with estrogen being the leading
hormone like there's got to be that has
to factor into it a little bit
unabomber in the harvard drug experiment
i mean you've got to admire the outfit
though that's style that's me in the
airport
um does it say anything in there if
psychology today has it too
okay where does it say that he was there
oh was it part of the mk ultra problem
yeah so what does it say about ted
kaczynski does it say that in there
i'm 99 sure he was a part of the study i
wouldn't be surprised i mean
if if [ __ ] manson was it's like they
had like
the nba starting lineup of serial
killers
just to google uh ted kaczynski there it
is
analysis of the personality of adolf
hitler
wow and that's a thing like how what are
when you think of the
the circles of psychology and how many
overlap how many are overlapping with
people like hitler and
ted kanzinski and all of these like what
are the what are those
common denominators amongst them because
that's what we
have to figure out is people who study
the brain and
and study behavioral patterns that's
really going to tell us a lot but you're
right like
will and what are the two factors
determinism or free words free will
right and i used to think much more
that it was free will because i'm a
stubborn person i used to think [ __ ] you
figure it out bro like when i was
younger in particular i get that but the
more i talk to
people that really understand the
concept the more it
it let me relax my grip on my opinion
which is very important right when you
you have an opinion about something
it's very important to examine how much
of a grip you have on this opinion and
whether or not this opinion is connected
to
you judging your own intelligence are
you in a like a game with people
were your opinions better than their
opinion like are you married to these
ideas
well it's hard for people as well
because of cognitive dissonance like we
have
a natural reaction to learning new
things 100
well we we have we like things to fall
in line
with whatever we've already yeah what
have we very assumed is our ideas
so this is this study and it says uh
another ethically problematic and this
is a [ __ ] up story
ethically problematic study was
conducted by uh
henry a murray murray was a professor
murray was a professor at harvard
university and had worked with the
office of strategic
services the predecessor to the cia well
i was before the cia they didn't just
they didn't have a good name yet what
are we gonna call just strategic
services
just put it on the on the door what
sounds better central intelligence
agency or the office of strategic
services strategic services is too hard
to say it's so hard to say
it's too cumbersome neither of us have
said it correct right
that's true yeah but strategic services
like
like if someone's got a gun in your head
what are you doing here i'm from the
office of
association you have two strategic
service men in your
in your office yeah i agree with the
name cia it's a better name i'll say
okay so during world war ii he wrote an
analysis of the personality of adolf
hitler
which was a psychological psychological
analysis
of hitler that was using the people i
could just come up with a better word
why psychological so long
[Laughter]
the mind of analysis of hitler it was
used by the military and during this
time
he also helped develop tests to screen
soldiers conducting
conducted as tests on brainwashing and
determined how well soldiers could
withstand
interrogations so what they were trying
to do is break people
so they took this is what's crazy about
it they took these students
and they would do things to them they
would interrogate them and [ __ ] with
them
and they would also dose them and so
the interrogation studies it says
included intense
mock interrogations on soldiers as part
of assessing the limits of their
psychological breaking points
okay that's a little perverse right he
conducted
such interrogation studies on harvard
university undergraduates
theodore kaczynski who later later
became known as the unabomber was
one of the 22 participants in murray's
study
subjected to several years of
interrogations
designed to psychologically break the
young man
so why aren't the people who have run
these studies
under the same interrogation that the
soldiers
of world war ii were under where we went
after the [ __ ] nazis we should be
going after
people who ran these terrible tests and
basically created
some of society's most prominent and
infamous serial killers that's a night
you're right
and it's a nice way of looking at it
that we just he deserves punishment we
deserve revenge and all that
not him the people that judged him yes
and all that his victims deserve revenge
yes but what i'm interested in
is that this man like if karma is
real if that's real if like what you
are today is in your next lifetime
chain of lies that you live that have
brought you to this and you're thinking
of yourself
in this inc incarnation because this is
the only one you've ever known
but in reality you're the process of
this long
line of beings that has gone on since
the beginning of life itself
you have all the ancestry in you what
did that guy do in another life
think about if that's true i'm not
saying it's true but imagine if it is
let's just as a thought experiment
imagine if it is that you're gonna come
back as a guy who is ignored
in this place because they're treating
you with some rando disease that you got
that most babies don't get
so you have these horrible hives they
keep you in this
place where they take care of children
for weeks they don't let you visit them
a couple of times a week
however long they kept them there i
don't know how i don't remember i want
to say it was two months
and we know your numbers are a little
off it could be it could be an
hour he was there for 45 years he was
there most of his life
he let him out in college so he he gets
out of there
and then his brother would talk about
these like moments of rage that he would
have that would be terrifying
and that like like if a girl rejected
him particularly he would write like
horrific notes to them like really mean
mean notes and then this guy goes and
does these harvard studies where they
[ __ ] with him relentlessly and they're
trying to break him it's almost like
they
knew that this was a guy that was
unusually broken
right and susceptible to breaking in the
way that would benefit their study
god especially like when you think about
the male brain
and the formative years go well into
your into your
freaking 20s and you're yeah like 25 to
the
frontal cortex i think it's females too
i think maybe you guys are a little
quicker
we're a little bit quicker we're like 18
19 but you know
still like he's on the heels of his
brain barely being and they're dosing
them with
acid and trying to break them
psychologically and doing like
mocking alone as a child on
the the playground although i do think
it's a necessary
passage into adulthood just to deal with
adversity
mocking alone is brutal and then you add
it to this study with
lsd being thrown into the mix where your
brain is not on a solid ground
the way it's going to process everything
is obviously detrimental to
who you become and it changes your it
changes your brain chemistry
you know i think there's like a problem
a real undeniable problem
with having secrecy what do you mean if
you're like an organization that has
ultimate power like the cia i see in the
1950s
and you can run these studies and no one
knows about them and you're giving kids
acid and you're trying to break them
it's that's why i said it's
her first crazy [ __ ] to him who knows
what they did to him right and it's like
is it really for your [ __ ] study
or are you guys just bored or do you
just get to do this
right it's something you get to do and
you're just pushing the ticket because
you can and you're funded that's so
demented
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video and
audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode of the joe rogan experience